coronavirus doesn't discriminate that
was a common refrain at the beginning of
the pandemic
but people and systems do in the u.s the
virus is magnifying existing social ills
and inequalities statistics show that
black americans are more likely to die
from the virus
than whites worldwide it is america
first
in total cases and deaths experts point
to the country's lack of pandemic
preparation
and the political division over
prevention measures
with case numbers gradually falling once
again can the u.s ward off another spike
of infections and deaths
that fall disproportionately on its most
vulnerable
[Music]
one foot in one foot out depending on
the very weak u.s president donald
trump's response to
even his very belief in the novel
coronavirus seems to change
now the pandemic may remain an
inconvenience for the president
but for many americans it's a hairwing
saga
around 40 000 americans are still
becoming infected with covet 19
every day nearly 200 000 people in the
usa have so far died
from the consequences of or with the
virus
the worst affected are poorer us
citizens especially african americans
as part of the banking system at the
beginning of the pandemic
nobody expected it to go like this not
even the u.s president
he initially played down the danger of
the virus ignoring the warnings of
health officials
it's going to disappear one day it's
like a miracle it will disappear
looks like by april you know in theory
when it gets a little warmer it
miraculously goes away hope that's true
but the number of infections has risen
rapidly and the us has become the
country with the most coronavirus cases
worldwide
new york hospitals were pushed to the
limit shortly after individual governors
began to lock down their states in march
trump raised hopes that the country
would open up soon i'm also hopeful
to have americans working again by that
easter that beautiful easter day
meanwhile americans have had to deal
with wildly differing statements
trump's advice often blankly contradicts
the recommendations of his health
officials
in this way he ignored advice to wear a
face mask in public for a long time
instead he made fun of his democratic
rival joe biden for appearing in a mask
at a memorial day event
on top of this trump has spread
misinformation for example that children
are immune to covet 19
or suggesting that injecting
disinfectant could work as a treatment
and then i see the disinfectant where it
knocks it out
in a minute by injection
inside or or almost a cleaning tons
it sounds interesting to me some i don't
think
later he explained their mark was meant
ironically when the number of cases rose
in june and july after the initial
easing
the president adopted a different tone
resuming his daily coronavirus briefings
trump expressly recommended wearing
masks
he even recommended against going to
bars
and i say if you can use the mask
then this month came another surprise us
journalist robert woodward's latest book
rage hit the bookshelves the book said
trump knew covet 19 was deadlier than
the flu
in february
it goes through air bob that's always
tougher than the touch you know the
touch you don't have to touch things
right but the air
you just breathe the air and that's how
it's passed
and so that's a very tricky one that's a
very delicate one
the message was a perfect point of
attack for biden
[Music]
[Applause]
the presidential election takes place in
early november
over 109 at a campaign appearance in
michigan
biden summed up his views well experts
say
that if he had acted just just one week
sooner 36 000 people would have been
saved
if he acted two weeks sooner back in
march 54
000 lives would have been spared in
march and april alone
and so the usa remains the country with
the highest number of infections in the
world
the number of unemployed after months of
lockdown in many states
remains high
let's take a closer look at just how
disproportionately the pandemic has hit
american communities
these numbers are from the midwestern
state of wisconsin where white residents
make up 80 percent of the population
but 67 percent of infections
by comparison black residents make up
only 6 percent of the population
but 11 percent of current infection and
close to 20 percent
of deaths a similar dissimilar
disproportionality with hispanics
we should note however that the ethnic
category hispanic can overlap with white
and black
all right let's dig a little deeper into
this with joshua garun he's an assistant
professor at the university of wisconsin
in madison
where he studies the sociology of public
health josh it's good to have you with
us
help us put this disparity in
perspective why are minorities more
likely to get coveted and die from it in
wisconsin
well the answer to that question is
really based on the intertwining of
racism and capitalism in the united
states if we take a step back and you
really think of any group
and you limit the places they can live
and you limit the places they can work
and you limit their transportation
and you limit their wealth and you do
that for a long enough
period of time you segregate them and
then you
introduce a pandemic these are the sorts
of effects you're going to see in
any group and that's what we've done in
the united states we've racialized that
we've created a racial hierarchy
and this is what we've done to to black
people to brown people to indigenous
people
we've disenfranchised them we've
disinvested in them
disinvested in their neighborhoods and
their workplaces
we have literally destroyed their homes
their businesses their livelihoods
really their lives their bodies and we
have done this
over a long period of time that's the
american experience that's the american
experiment
and if you keep running that same
experiment over a long enough period of
time
you are going to get these same results
over hundreds of years you're going to
get these results when a pandemic
emerges
the pandemic does not create new
realities on the ground in terms of the
racial realities
of the united states it simply
exacerbates the existing
uh realities the existing inequalities
and that's what we've been seeing
in the country and that's what we've
been seeing in wisconsin especially in
the city of milwaukee
josh to what extent does social benefits
play a role or the access or lack of
access to social benefits such as health
insurance or
paid care paid paid leave time i should
say
absolutely it's enormous and that's
enormous universally
but again what we've done in this
country is that we have
created the racial order in which the
people who are most likely not to have
access to those benefits which are not
universal anyhow
are ethnic and racial minorities so they
are people they are brown people people
of color indigenous people
they are on average less likely to have
access to those exact benefits
and as as as anyone could guess if you
don't have access to health care health
insurance if you don't have access
to some sort of secure income a
guaranteed income
uh or to food or to housing or any of
these things
uh you are going to suffer when the
pandemic hits that
uh carves out uh the the basics of life
in many ways and creates these
difficulties
now some people might argue this is
about more about
poverty urban poverty or socioeconomic
status you would say that those two
things socioeconomic status and
race here in the u.s are much more tied
together and tethered together and
that's why we see these results is that
fair to say
absolutely from the beginning that's the
history of this country is the
intertwining the tethering of race
and and political economy of race and
economics
uh you cannot understand the story of
the united states
without understanding how racism and
capitalism are inextricably connected
and have been from the start
all right josh caron with the university
of wisconsin thank you very much
thank you all right now it's time for
your questions
to our science correspondent derek
williams
can you contract covet 19 through a
blood transfusion
in general diseases that primarily
affect
the respiratory system are are not known
to be transmitted
via blood transfusions and and according
to national health authorities
like the who and and the european center
for disease prevention and control
there have been no documented cases so
far
of that happening with covet 19. despite
that reassurance
lots of people have worried about this
question i think
because of the reports that the virus
can cause blood clotting particularly
in in later stages of the disease but it
looks like
that symptom though indirectly driven by
the virus
is actually probably directly due to
to deadly cascades that it sets in
motion in the immune system
that lead to hyperactivity in in blood
clotting cells
not by viruses in your bloodstream that
said
since a few studies have shown traces of
virus
and a small percentage of blood samples
from people who caught
covet 19 most organizations that take
blood donations are now also
taking a lot of precautionary measures
as they collect it
they'll probably now check your
temperature before you donate
for starters and you should also expect
to fill out a questionnaire
detailing your your travel history um if
you've had covet 19
and when how you felt in the last four
weeks and and whether
you're aware of any possible exposures
and of course
if you test positive for the virus
anytime within a few weeks
after donation um you should definitely
inform the collecting agency
all those precautions i think uh make
sense
but but in general if transfusions were
a common way
to pass on this disease i believe that
by now we'd have heard
of of many cases where it happened and
and we haven't
[Music]